in 15 14 13 12 11 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
1 los geht's
los gehts und herzlich willkommen bei
easy german life schön dass ihr alle
dabei seit wir begrüßen euch bei youtube
und bei facebook live wir sind heute in
berlin live auf der straße janisch und
ich sind nicht auf der straße zuerst
begrüße ich mal meinen co host des
heutigen tages hallo
hallo
wo bist du gerade
also ich bin der ungefähr
ein zimmer von dir entfernt in der
gleichen wohnung bei uns ist es warm und
gemütlich und wir freuen uns schon auf
das treffen was uns davor steht genau
wir treffen nämlich jetzt virtuell
unseren rasenden reporter manuel
saalmann hallo manuel hallo ihr beiden
ich stehe hier mit rabatt an der kamera
und mir hinterm mikrofon vor dem
berliner ostbahnhof daran können wir
schon erkennen wir sind im osten berlins
und es ist kalt ja das ist ja toll
manuel du bist live heute wieder
unterwegs letzte letzten monat waren wir
auf dem alexanderplatz jetzt bist du am
ostbahnhof was gibt es denn dort zu
sehen heute also im ostbahnhof selbst
gibt es nicht so viel zu sehen ich bin
dort gerade angekommen mit der s bahn
und es war sehr viel baustelle
konstruktion wie so oft in berlin aber
wir sind auch gar nicht hier um den
ostbahnhof zu sehen sondern um das zu
sehen was ich jetzt schon aus dem
augenwinkel sehe und ich würde sagen wir
machen uns auf den weg und du kannst ja
mal erklären was das ziel heute ist
alles klammern ul dann würde ich sagen
ihr geht los wir gucken euch zu also
wenn ihr mal in berlin seit dann ist das
der ort zudem manuel jetzt geht ein
absolutes highlight es ist die east side
gallery und das ist das längste
erhaltene teil stück der berliner mauer
ihr kennt vielleicht die lina mauer sie
hat berlin geteilt für viele jahre lang
und
1989 wurde sie aufgebrochen und damit
änderte auch die teilung deutschlands
und wir wollen heute mal gucken wie die
mauer heute noch aussieht also
eigentlich ist sie weg aber an einigen
stellen steht sie noch und manuel geht
jetzt gleich zu der stelle an der man
das größte stück sieht und es ist heute
eine kunstgalerie das können wir schon
verraten
manuela ist die polizei am ostbahnhof
was ist denn da los du ich glaube das
gehört einfach zu einem großen bahnhof
dazu dass polizei in der nähe ist also
hier ist alles ruhig nicht viel los was
ich dir erzählen kann wenn du etwas aus
meinem leben hören möchtest ist dass
sich in diesem gebäude dieses
backsteingebäude da war ich vor vielen
jahren mal auf einem konzert vor corinna
zeiten leider habe ich vergessen wie die
künstlerin hieß ich war nämlich nur dort
weil einer freundin von mir als vor band
gespielt hat aber ich hatte schöne
erinnerungen und genau dahinter ist noch
die die mercedes benz arena
das ist eine große arena wo dann so
bands wie coldplay spielen aber da war
ich noch nie ich glaube ich auch noch
nicht ist es interessant wie viele teile
in berlin wo früher die mauer stand da
ist heute also wurde in den letzten 30
jahren sehr viel gebaut und so ist auch
dieser teil an dem du jetzt bist ein ort
wo es sehr viele neue gebäude gibt und
es wird immer noch sehr viel gebaut also
man muss sagen nach 30 jahren ist das
noch nicht zu ende es wird immer noch
umgebaut ja während manuel läuft mit
report werden wir mal unsere zuschauer
begrüßen auf youtube und facebook und
wir wollen euch fragen wo ihr gerade
seid aus welchem land guckt ihr zu
schreibt uns mal einen kommentar maria
hat schon mal geschrieben und sagt hallo
aus polen
bryant hat geschrieben hallo aus
singapur
emerson ist in kolumbien
egal in indonesien ist sind viele
verschiedene orte heute user guckt uns
auf facebook aus marokko
paulo aus hannah police in brasilien
kasachstan haben wir dabei syrien
so schnell geht das jetzt bochum aus
abidjan japan jordanien
ich komme nicht mehr hinterher leute
taiwan
russland bosnien
vietnam
indien menschen aus der ganzen welt
gucken und zu janesch manuel was sagt
ihr dazu das ist der wahnsinn
manuel du bist schon angekommen wir sind
schon angekommen tatsächlich geht es
hier los und wir können ja erstmal hier
ein detail zeigen also hier ist eine
kleine
[Musik]
plakette auf der steht berliner mauer
east side gallery dort stehen ein paar
daten nämlich das datum als die mauer
gebaut wurde und als sie gefallen ist
und dann sieht man auch dass man kurz
danach schon ein paar monate nachdem die
mauer gefallen ist begonnen hat hier
also kunst drauf zu malen böhmer
das ist das los des werbe schmalen dämon
ahnung ja das ist also ein denkmal das
steht hier noch und man muss aufpassen
hier gibt es viele touristen und
deswegen gibt es natürlich hier auch
trickbetrüger aber dass heute sehr kalt
ist denke ich werden wir davon niemanden
antreffen ja und ich würde sagen ich
weiß nicht sagen wir einfach jetzt mal
langsam vorbei gehen und ihr ruft stoppt
wenn ihr euch ein kunstwerk genauer
anschauen wollt oder wollen wir
vielleicht mal ganz kurz noch auf die
andere seite gucken also das ist
vielleicht noch interessant zu sagen das
hier war also der berliner osten also
jetzt stehe ich im ehemaligen ostteil
von berlin und naja also streng hinter
der spree beginnt dann der west teil
also der spree der fluss der große fluss
in berlin der ist da drüben den werden
wir später auch noch sehen
aber ja hier ist also die andere seite
der mauer und man kann das hier finde
ich sehr eindrucksvoll sehen sag ich mal
wie hoch die war und wie die verlaufen
ist
ja und das ist sogar nur ein stück der
mauer es gab eigentlich eine außenmauer
und eine innen mauer also das ist jetzt
und das äußere stück wir können
vielleicht mal ein foto einblenden wo
man sieht wie diese straße auf der du
bist früher außer das war nämlich
tatsächlich
einfach eine normale straße man konnte
dort herfahren und
links sieht man jetzt die mauer an der
du stehst oder vielleicht von oben
gesehen noch mal da sieht man diese
mauer mann dazwischen war einfach ein
grüner streifen und der fluss der war
dann eigentlich die grenze auf der
rechten seite und es gab also auch
menschen die versucht haben berlin zu
verlassen in dem sie über das wasser
also geschwommen sind
ja mal zeigt uns noch mal ein paar
kunstwerke ich habe vorher ein bisschen
recherchiert ich habe mich schlau
gemacht damit wir hier nicht
gefährliches halbwissen verbreiten
und wir sehen wir einst von amnesty
international scheinbar mit der
friedenstaube
ich finde das ist schon mal ein schönes
manuel reagiert auf kunst
jetzt jetzt zeigt sich was für ein
kunstbanausen weil ich wahrscheinlich
den wirklichen kerlen hier gar nicht
erkenne aber gut
ja das ist tatsächlich so gewesen dass
ich damals also schon 1989 das war ja so
im sozialismus wurden die künstler ja
durch den staat beauftragt und bezahlt
also meistens zumindest
und plötzlich brach den künstlern in der
ddr nach dem ende des staates brachen
die ganzen aufträge weg und sie haben
dann schnell die zusammenarbeit gesucht
und es gab quasi zwei kunst
künstlervereinigungen in ostdeutschland
wester schland die haben sich
zusammengetan um also gemeinsame lobby
für die künstler zu machen in ost und
west und die haben dann als erstes
gemeinsames projekt künstler aus ganz
deutschland und aus der ganzen welt
eingeladen um gemeinsam
ja diese dieses stück der mauer zu
bemalen
das auch mal nur das hier und
dass das recht
hier curriculum vitae da geht es um
flüchtlinge escape ist rettet
die stable eis dominion securities
also hier geht es um die erinnerung an
die flüchtlinge aus der ddr die du
gerade ja schon kurz erwähnt hast viele
leute haben versucht zu fliehen aus der
ddr einige haben es geschafft einige
mehrere viele sind auch ums leben
gekommen und darum geht's in diesem
kunstwerk januar zeigt meinen datum auf
die
kein datum jahren bist du denn nach
deutschland gekommen das muss
1984 gewesen sein dass das richtig ja
das ist richtig ja ja nur stroh hatte
das glück dass du mit einer fähre
fliehen konnte es darüber haben wir vor
einem halben jahr ein video gemacht und
in ja in berlin war das tatsächlich so
und in ostdeutschland dass dort auch auf
menschen geschossen wurde also das war
zu deiner zeit schon ja nicht so
gefährlich als du aus polen geflohen
bist du hattest nur angst dass du
vielleicht zurück muss das sein pass
weggenommen wird aber in der ddr mussten
ja haben viele leute ihr leben verloren
auch bei dem versuch
das ist unfair war heute kann man sich
solche
barbarische handlungen nicht mal
vorstellen
auf unbewaffnete leute von denen man
wusste er ganz genau wussten die wollen
nur dem scheiß land in entfliehen hin zu
familien sehr oft und da dass man darf
die leute hat schießen lassen ist
einfach unverzeihlich geschichtlich
unverzeihlich dass das kann man nicht
sehen war zeigt mal dass manuel das hier
ja du sagst sie haben nicht das ist
heute unvorstellbar aber in anderen
ländern passiert das ja immer noch also
diese brücke die hier abgebildet ist das
ist die oberbaumbrücke und dies da
drüben ich hoffe dass wir das schaffen
also noch kann man sie wahrscheinlich
auf dem live stream jetzt nicht erkennen
ich kann sie sehen wir legen gleich
einen zahn zu damit wir da auch noch
einen blick reinwerfen können aber das
ist diese bekannte brücke die trend die
stadtteile kreuzberg und friedrichshain
und da sieht man sie trinken h das ist
ein schöner ist das gefällt mir das wird
kommen das erste mal mit dem laptop und
darauf und kaffee was würdest du niemals
machen einen kaffee aus ist das laptop
das sieht aus wie ein einkaufskorb der
hier lebt aber der rauch doch nicht
gerichtlich
würde auch nie wie beim tav
das ja was das stimmt
ist eine frage was sind diese purple
pipes oder pauls die hat man eben
gesehen ich war ja es ist tatsächlich
auch nicht weißt du das ja ich kann das
sagen also ich weiß nicht genau was
jetzt der spezifische zweck ist aber die
sind immer dafür da um wasser
abzutransportieren
also ich glaube bei baustellen wenn man
den boden aus gibt also wenn man ein
loch quasi macht um dort ein gebäude zu
bauen dann trifft man auch viel
grundwasser und das muss weg und wenn
man in der nähe einfluss hat so wie wir
hier die spree haben dann wird das über
diese rohre in die spree abgeleitet das
wasser
okay da weißt du mehr als ich mohammed
schreibt bis es dort immer so ruhig manu
das nein ich denke im sommer und
natürlich auch gerade zu
zeiten wo mehr tourismus noch herrscht
als jetzt vorsicht ist kommt fahrräder
hinter dir da
gibt es hier natürlich viele touristen
also das ist ja eine der
hauptattraktionen in berlin die man
sehen muss wenn man berlin besucht ganz
klar also wenn man im sommer an diesem
ort ist und wenn nicht corona ist dann
ist dieser dieser bürgersteig dieser
gehweg auf dem du jetzt gehst komplett
voll muss man sagen dann kann man nicht
einfach alleine vor dem bild stehen
sondern das ist doch ein schönes bild
ein trabi oder was ist das hier ja
nur du kannst du uns etwas erzählen zu
diesem auto
es war ein sehr ordentliches auto sehr
fortschrittlich ohne metall gebaut das
ganze karosserie war aus plastik
darunter war ein kleine kleines kleines
kleiner motor soll aber der fuhr dann
fuhr aber das besondere daran ist dass
es nur dieses auto gab in der ddr so
ludwig es gab noch war ein burg es gab
noch die wartburg und die hatten noch
irgendwas auf jeden fall man muss schon
sagen dass
ostdeutschland als start war der ddr
führen der staat in dem ganzen ostblock
also wirtschaftlich ging es den noch am
besten uns war immer
ich weiß irgendwann aufgrund irgendeiner
freundschaftsbekundungen haben die auch
deutsche erlaubt blind in polen ohne
visum nach ostdeutschland zu fahren und
die haben das aber schnell bedauert weil
die polen dann quasi massenhaft
angefallen sind und alles weg gekauft
haben was es zu kaufen gab aber naja
meine mama und meine oma ist mitgefahren
als dolmetscher dass deshalb weiß ich
dass
meine oma und meine oma hat auch erzählt
dass die aus deutschen verkäuferin den
oft ziemlich
verärgert waren wegen diesen
wegen dieser massenhaften
der anteil der ankaufs wittingen
mitbrüder aus polen ok und man musste
jahrelang warten auch auf so ein aus
oder also war nicht einfach
denn da ist da wohl hat noch
festgestellt das autokennzeichen auf dem
bild war vom november 89 tag des
mauerfalls ist uns wieder nicht
aufgefallen dass detail
anschauen möchte gerne wissen was ist
sein lieblingsbild war nur
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das noch nicht
ich habe ja noch nicht alle gesehen
und entscheide mich dann später wenn das
in ordnung ist also bis jetzt ist jetzt
fand ich
habe mich dass mit der friedenstaube
ganz schön
alles schön oder das ist in einem tunnel
ja das passiert häufiger mal in berlin
in berlin wird immer viel gebaut und als
fußgänger und oft leider auch als
fahrradfahrer muss man dann durch so
mega enge tunnel fahren das ist wirklich
gefährlich vorsicht da wird bereichert
wird fasst jetzt hier gegen das ding
gelaufen aber das gehört zum leben in
der großstadt dazu
würde ich sagen komm wir wechseln wie
das versteh
manuell diana hat mir gerade gesagt dass
mein mikrofon knackt das würde ich gerne
einmal testen das dass das mikrofon
knackt
was muss das müssen die hörer innen und
zuschauer einen uns mal einen kommentar
betont
erik und chris die bei uns hinter den
kulissen sitzen können uns auch einen
kommentar schreiben
vielleicht hat nur janisch dieses
problem gehört ich gehe mal zurück in
die kommentare und habe einen kommentar
von steven er schreibt ich finde es
schade dass eine mehrspurige straße
neben der mauer ist der gehweg sollte
ausgeweitet werden einige tagen ist es
zu eng und laut es ist doch so war oder
wie kann das sein sind 12 spuren auf
jeder seite dann noch mal eine spur für
parkende autos und die ganzen menschen
die sich dieses stück geschichte von
berlin anschauen wollen die teilen sich
ungefähr drei meter auf diesen bürger
steigt was ist denn das für eine
prioritätensetzung david übrigens
geratene auto abgeschleppt auch ganz
spannend
oder wird es da wieder hingesetzt wir
wissen es nicht so genau vielleicht wird
es auch abgeliefert
sieht irgendwie so ein bisschen so aus
als würden die das hier parken naja also
immer spannend was hier so passen also
kennen schreibt nein ist knackig ronaldo
schreibt sendung ohne probleme marcia
schreibt kein problem mit dem mikrofon
und alina schreibt alles gut also
vielleicht hört nur janisch das knacken
würde ich sagen schade für janisch aber
gut für alle anderen ja manchmal diese
mauer es viel länger noch als ich dachte
ja und zwar 1,3 kilometer und damit das
längste stück der mauer das noch
überhaupt existiert und auch die längste
open air galerie der welt habe ich
gelesen
caprio oder kaputt schreibt wie kalt ist
es dort manuell hier grad celsius
4 grad das ist für würdest du sagen für
januar in berlin kalt oder warm moderat
ich glaube das guck mal das ist glaube
ich mein neues lieblings
gemeldet das ist so richtig schön
wild
steht noch
die rechte an diesem bild gehören mir
der geschichte der mauer der wahrheit
gott und allen menschen
das ist wirklich schön
ich habe eine schöne eine schöne frage
von ladislav er fragt was denkt
eigentlich die jüngere generation über
die berliner mauer und die ereignisse
vor der wiedervereinigung von
deutschland manuel da frage ich direkt
mal dich du bist ja die jüngere
generation du bist zwei jahre vor der
wiedervereinigung geboren
du kennst nur das eigentlich das
gemeinsame deutschland was denkst du
über diese zeit
ich denke dass das natürlich ein
ziemlich trauriges kapitel ist unserer
geschichte und gleichzeitig aber auch
ein
ein teil unserer geschichte der hoffnung
stimmt denn es gibt ja noch viele mauern
auf der welt und die
teilung deutschlands und dann die
wiedervereinigung hat bewiesen dass das
geht dass man als geteiltes volk oder
als ja zwei nationen die sich
gegenüberstehen auch wieder
zusammenkommen kann und da gibt es ja
noch viele andere länder auf der welt
die
darauf noch die hoffnung haben
da fast zu schön gesagt nein danke hier
ist übrigens die mercedes benz arena wo
ich dachte dass coldplay tickets ab denn
für dieses jahr wenn mal gespannt ob das
stattfinden kann toll sind wir jetzt
gesponsert von mercedes und auch nicht
von coldplay aber ich dachte ich es mal
was es hier so gibt wir haben einige
fragen bekommen manuel die werde ich
jetzt mal gehör lesen anderes möchte
gerne wissen leidet die mauer ab und zu
von unter vandalismus wer schützt die
mauer ja absolut sie leidet unter
vandalismus und natürlich auch einfach
unter dem wetter unter wettereinflüssen
das ist ja draussen hier und deswegen
gibt es einen verein
ich glaube der steht hier auch irgendwo
drauf der sich quasi darum kümmert dass
hier in den stand zu halten und auch die
kunstwerke
es gibt hier kunstwerke die quasi schon
seit 1990 hier sind das sind aber längst
nicht mehr die originalen also die
mussten neu gemalt werden weil das
natürlich
mich hält über so viele jahre ja die
wurden tatsächlich nochmal bemalt wenn
wir gleich ein bekanntes kunstwerke
sehen kann ich das mal zeigen dann
daniele möchte wissen gibt es noch teile
der mauer die noch nicht bemalt wurden
auf diesem stück nicht mehr da ist alles
schon mehrfach bemalt aber es gibt noch
ein anderes stück da können wir
vielleicht in der zukunft mal einen
livestream machen an der bernauer straße
gibt es eine gedenkstätte und da sieht
man tatsächlich noch die original mauer
mit der grenze manuel du bist an einem
besonderen ort angekommen bio und es
gibt ja richtig eine schlange eine fotos
schlange ich glaube ich muss mich mal
ein rein bis ich mich davor stellen darf
denn tatsächlich möchten alle ein foto
machen von diesem kunstwerk
aber da sich keiner hinstellt mache ich
das jetzt einfach mal und du kannst mal
kurz erklären worum es hier geht ja
dieses kunstwerk ist der heißt
bruderkuss es ist das kunstwerk des
russischen malers
dmitri wrubel wir haben interessieren
sich zufällig schon einmal interviewt in
einer easyjet episode ja aber ich habe
leider vergessen in welcher episode es
ist immer sehr schon vier oder fünf
jahre her aber wir machen das ja dieser
dieses bild vielleicht kann rawert das
gleich nochmal von weitem zeigen es
zeigt ein
sowjetisches ritual ja noch was sehen
wir dort
wir sehen dort für zwei
statt
häupl heute
statt die oberhäupter
staatsoberhäupter die sich einen
rituellen brüder kuss geben also
wahrscheinlich ist der wäsche jetzt nach
aus deutschland gekommen und honecker
hat ihn begrüßt und die haben die haben
sich so einen dicken
schmatzer auf die lippen gegeben auf den
mund und das befremdet bis heute so ein
bisschen aber damals war das sind ritual
damals war das so eine visualisierung
dass wir brüder sind und im guten und
den schlechten
ja es gab richtig in der sowjetunion ein
zeremoniell oder ein protokoll wie man
sich begrüßt es gab ja auch bestimmte
begrüßungen so und man hat sich bei
staatsbesuchen das war jetzt gerade
leonid breschnew der rückt das russische
staatsoberhaupt und erich honecker
staatsoberhaupt der ddr hat man sich so
begrüßt ich möchte euch noch ein bild
zeigen dass wir vorbereitet
und dort sieht man nämlich ganz gut auf
diesem bild wie der dimitri vrubel
dieses bild nachzeichnet also er hat das
1990 im original gemalt und 2009 also
vor 13 jahren wurde diese mauer
restauriert und hier sieht man wie er
das bild noch mal neu
nachgezeichnet übermalt hat quasi
ich muss mich übrigens korrigieren es
gibt doch noch freie flächen scheinbar h
also hier ist alles weiß ich hätte mal
ein paar sprühdosen mitbringen sollen
dann hätte ich
ganz dicke easyjet
genau weiß ich nicht ob das hier selbst
auch schon kunst ist oder ob das eine
vorbereitung ist für ein weiteres steht
das ist nur die gleiche plakette hiervon
immer wo draufsteht wenn die mauer
gefallen ist also da steht nichts ja gut
dann werden nur noch die nächsten
kunstwerke vorbereitet du kannst dich ja
mal
bewerben
wie chris möchte wissen gab es tunnel
unter der mauer
ja das gab es und zwar sowohl
gescheiterte versuche als auch
erfolgreiche versuche nicht so viele es
gibt auch einen sehr guten film der
heißt glaube ich der tunnel
wo man das sehen kann so einen dieser
fluchtversuche
kim möchte wissen können wir mal in den
mauerpark gehen der ist jetzt
tatsächlich am anderen ende der stadt
aber vielleicht machen wir das in
zukunft mal eine episode aus dem
mauerwerk
gute idee ich habe noch eine ganz tolle
frage für dich manuell von jenni sie
möchte wissen ist berlin immer grau
gefühl schon acht monate im jahr
ungefähr
und dann hat man vier monate ein
bisschen sonne ich übertreibe jetzt ja
ganz so schlimm ist es nicht aber der
winter ist schon sehr grau muss man
sagen und so ein wetter wie heute
ist halt einfach typisch eine typisch
berliner winter
das ist so muss man wissen nach berlin
kommt nicht so viel sonne kannst du mal
dort kannst du mal den himmel zeigen
gar nicht schlecht es gibt wolken
gladys love hat uns eine info
geschrieben leonid breschnew war für
seinen bruder küsst seine bruder küsse
in der sowjetunion ganz bekannt es gab
viele scherze darüber
und jenny möchte
gibt es keine masken pflicht in berlin
nur in innenräumen in bahnen restaurants
und so weiter aber nicht in
also draußen auf dem bürgersteig schaut
man leute ich habe einen trabi entdeckt
schön
leider ist es abgeschlossen sonst dachte
ich könnte mir eine kleine tour machen
aber was ist schön man sieht richtig wie
klein und kompakt der war
und ja hinten eine sitzbank da saßen
dann die kinder drauf
ist doch toll oder was es hier alles
gibt
ja nie freut sich dass du auf ihre frage
geantwortet hast schuppen schreibt
manuel ist immer lustig danke ja gar
nicht versuchen den hierauf so machst du
denn da das ist sachbeschädigung manuel
ich wollte ich dachte er gucken mal
unter die haube
du bist hier aber eine
ganz schön frech
hier mal eine kleine hausmitteilung
everett everett möchte wissen wie oft
machen sie einen livestream manuel
kannst du uns diese frage beantworten ja
das kann ich sehr gerne im moment einmal
im monat und zwar meistens am dritten
mittwoch des monats muss unser plan
dann haben wir noch ein zwei fragen
vielleicht können wir noch zwei drei
beantworten bevor wir gleich an unseren
finalen ort kommen anni möchte wissen
wer darf seine kunst auf der maur
verewigen jeder oder wird ausgewählt und
wenn ja wie und wer welt aus ich glaube
so ganz genau wissen wir das nicht wer
die kunst aus welt es gibt dort einen
verein wie manuel gerade schon gesagt
hat der sich um die mauer kümmert und
ich schätze dass der verein das auch aus
welt also jeder manuel darf da jetzt
nicht einfach malen auf dem rhein
definitiv nicht das ist künstlern
vorbehalten carré ich bin schlecht
vorbereitet wie kommen wir denn jetzt
überhaupt auf die brücke drauf müssen
wir hier genauso ganz oben gar nicht
drauf da erfährt ja nur die u-bahn haben
zehn jahre
stimmt wir sind ja schon oben quasi ich
dachte wir könnten noch höher aber da
ist nur die u-bahn was auch keinen sinn
macht ist ist ja die u-bahn die müsste
ja eigentlich unter richtig aber das war
gerade schon ein sehr schönes bild wie
die gelbe u bahn über die brücke
gefahren ist ja ja ich weiß nicht wie
jetzt darunter kommt wahrscheinlich
müsst ihr jetzt zum wasser laufen darf
doch mal da den gehweg weiter
darunter ja nicht wir gehen jetzt hier
über die ampel und dann schauen wir
gleich mal was es da hinten gibt das
hier ist übrigens universe großes
sagt man musik label ja und genau also
nochmal zur orientierung rechts von mir
also da hinten hinter der brücke ist
kreuzberg und in diese richtung ist
friedrich seien sehr bekannt für die
vielen clubs
technoclubs und sonstige oder kommt der
polizei gehört natürlich auch immer
dabei dazu in berlin leute ich gleich
noch mal ein bild kurz damit ihr seht wo
wir jetzt sind manuel ist die ganze
mauer entlang gelaufen und hinten rechts
seht ihr eine brücke und da ist manuel
jetzt und so sah das aus 1900 in den
80ern ich weiß nicht genau wann und
jetzt bist du schon unter der brücke
wichtig ist es sehr dunkel hier ich weiß
nicht ob ihr überhaupt noch was seht ja
aber genau dieser teil ist auch sehr
bekannt weil also ich assoziiere mit
dieser brücke die feiernden die
tatsächlich nach in den clubs sind und
dann hier also wenn man hier
samstag nachts um drei ist in nicht
coroner zeiten dann sind hier viele
betrunkene die nach hause gehen würde
ich sagen ja
und das andere was es hier gibt ist ein
wunderschöner ausblick auf die spree
hier sieht man auch mal wie weit also
wie breit die spree überhaupt ist wahr
und genau wir haben ja letztens noch
eine bootstour gemacht
letzten dass das war eben oktober
ja
manuel die oberbaumbrücke wurde 1895
gebaut
das großen länger herne
übrigens ich habe noch eine lustige
geschichte zu der east side gallery
die haben nämlich am anfang sponsoren
gesucht oder die haben erst mal geguckt
wer ein partner sein könnte und die
amerikanische botschaft hat dann
vorgeschlagen oder die haben sponsoren
gesucht und das ganze projekt sollte
erstmal von mcdonald's und coca cola
gesponsert werden
da haben dann aber die künstler gesagt
nee das passt nicht zu unserer kunst und
dann ja dann lieber
kein sponsoring so
ungefähr war das ja nicht wie fühlst du
dich ja sie nostalgisch
gerne auch gerne draußen mit manuel
heute nicht unbedingt aber so in vier
monaten ja
noch eine frage von serie gibt es in
berlin gebäude die vor dem zweiten
weltkrieg gebaut wurden definitiv viele
also plan a steht gerade auf einer
brücke die wurde schon vor dem sehr weit
vor dem krieg gebaut ich wohne auch in
einem haus das schon 100
127 jahre alt ist glaube ich oder 117
oder so habe ich einen brief vom
vermieter bekommen wo das mit drinstand
ja schon sehr alt ja richtig und
wir wurden auch in einem haus was schon
über 120 jahre alt ist also das gibt es
sehr oft manuell willkommen wir zu einem
ende wir haben noch viele fragen
bekommen zum beispiel wo wart ihr als
die mauer gefallen es viele fragen zur
mauer ich würde sagen die beantworten
wir in einer anderen episode wo wir
vielleicht noch mal zur bernauer straße
gehen das ist die gedenkstätte dort gibt
es viele informationen
zur flucht an der mauer zu dem mauerfall
selber und da können wir vielleicht noch
mal ein bisschen mehr erzählen über
diesen teil der geschichte sehr gerne
und wenn ihr fragen habt könnt ihr uns
auch immer fragen schicken für unseren
podcast easy german punkt fm dan carey
und ich wir machen zwei mal in der woche
einen podcast und dort beantworten wir
auch immer gerne fragen also da haben
sie ja auch ein bisschen mehr zeit
absolut so sieht es aus easy germany ist
unser podcast zum schluss möchte ich
mich noch bedanken bei dem ganzen team
manuel und rabat unsere rasenden
reporter jetzt im sonnenuntergang schon
fast dunkel
janisch hier bei mir in der wohnung
nebenan und dann haben wir noch chris
und eric die uns hinter den kulissen
geholfen haben und wir möchten uns
bedanken weil all unseren mitgliedern
die uns dieses projekt ermöglichen die
uns unterstützen das sind unsere patches
wenn ihr auch mitmachen möchte als
mitglied dann meldet euch gerne mal ein
an hier unten wird jetzt der link
angemeldet und da könnt ihr einen teil
von easy german werden ihr könnt mit uns
ketten ihr könnt übungen machen es
unseren videos ihr könnt transkripte
bekommen zum videos und zum podcast und
vieles mehr und wir freuen uns darüber
manuell wann werden wir wieder auf die
straße gehen
in einem monat in einem monat und im
buch gehen wir das thema wo gehen wir
dann hin was machen wir dann ich verrate
jetzt ein geheimnis wir entscheiden das
immer mega spontan wenn es nämlich vor
zwei tagen entschieden was wir heute
machen und dementsprechend wissen wir
das noch nicht aber ihr könnt uns ja
vorschläge schicken was wir hier sehen
in berlin und wir waren uns und schauen
uns das an das finde ich gut schreibt
uns mal einen vorschlag wir haben ja
schon einige ideen gesammelt wir werden
nochmal zum mauerpark gehen wir werden
bestimmt noch mal zur bernauer straße
gehen welche anderen orte möchtet ihr in
berlin sehen schreibt uns einen
kommentar unter dieses video und jetzt
sage ich ich bedanke mich bei euch wir
haben viele schöne kommentare bekommen
danke dass ihr zu gesehen habt und bis
bald liebe leute das wunderschönes bild
da im hintergrund manuel